it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we explore the cultural
stories of the day and for that we turn
to Fox News contributor and author the
best-selling the wise men who found
Christmas Raymond Arroyo Ray let's start
with this uh Dahmer series on Netflix
which is suddenly all their age I guess
well it's the second most watched series
on Netflix after stranger things Laura
and it reveals a troubling cultural
Trend serial killers is entertainment
now Look From Penny dreadfuls to Jack
the Ripper to Hannibal Lecter Killers
have always held a certain fascination
with the public but the grizzly nature
of Dahmer is disturbing I mean they are
trawling reality to create an
entertainment and that's what I think
makes this a little distressing and it's
so graphic
well I have to say not only have I not
watched it but I don't plan to watch it
it's just I
violence violent things anymore I can't
do you know watch the stuff I just can't
do it I don't like it I feel the same
way and you know I can't do what you're
talking about there were 17 victims here
and the families are really up in arms
about this because it does it's taking
their lives and their tragedy and sort
of sensationalizing it for entertainment
and the dominant thing is that he's not
alone there's Dexter Criminal Minds that
TV show Hannibal visual how-to manuals
for psychopaths and you
me what did I do I've never done a
serial killer show no are you on Netflix
I'm not on Netflix Laura I know the show
you
neither the personal nor the show me
Laura have ever done anything on serial
killers can we stay on topic all right
yeah I don't know what you don't
understand all right this is on topic
never mind
tell us about this morning console poll
okay now this is very concerning a new
poll shows two-thirds of adults say they
are fans of serial killer movies or
shows and 80 percent of Millennials now
Laura the problem with this is you know
uh you you you spend enough time
marinating in this material and it not
only normalizes very graphic and really
the most disgusting actions of one human
to another but it builds sympathy for
these serial killers and that is that to
me is the major problem here normalizing
the behavior and the sympathy it
engenders I remember I watched that
Helter Skelter move me as a kid and I
was I think I had nightmares for months
after that I think I still have
nightmares if it's horrible but yeah
this is what this is what this is what
we do marinade in now now as long as
we're talking about sick films a
Congressional candidate in New York is
starring in a new one Ray yeah well none
that will want to see talk about Helter
Skelter his name is Mike itkus he is an
independent trying to unseat Jerry
Nadler that may be difficult to unseat
Jerry Nadler but uh to show how
committed he is to sex positivity as an
agenda he's appearing in a porn film
Laura called bucket list Bonanza
basically he supports legalizing
prostitution and abortion on demand itka
says if I would just talk about it it
wouldn't demonstrate my commitment to
the issue and the fact that I actually
did it was a huge learning experience
and it actually influenced items on my
platform perhaps he now supports STD
coverage
items I items I don't even want to think
about what the items are on his agenda
at this point I mean it should be ickes
his name should be ickes okay well well
thank God he doesn't support euthanasia
or the death penalty you know this could
have gotten really gory be it with
Dahmer uh this weekend saw some pretty
spooky on-camera moments though Laura
like any horror movie they often occur
in the most pedestrian of places like
this ice cream parlor where President
Biden stopped during a West Coast Swing
he casually chatted up a lady and then
then he leaned in and he went in
for the sniff it never fails watch this
look oh oh again there he goes oh
another oh he did two Snips Raymond that
was two Snips in one stop I mean I
usually you go into an ice cream place
like I was in Shady Glen in Manchester
Connecticut over the weekend and you
want a mint chip cone but he just wants
a sniff
yeah
called the ice cream go for the sniff
all right his travels now contain real
suspense too like when you cornered this
poor young girl you know you know he
wants to you know another Sniff was
there another yeah well you know the
viewer viewers tense up when they watch
this Laura and then he goes in but then
he doesn't do it you know but look more
victims await no doubt during his next
outing they really should give him there
should be a bubble Zone around any young
woman and Joe Biden just so he doesn't
you need one of those out there consent
you need one of those clear umbrellas
from the 70s all those big ones and walk
around all right where are you on the
book tour where are you wearing the
victim Library tomorrow night and then
in L.A at the Grove on Wednesday so I
hope everybody will come out at
raymondarroyo.com all the details are
there and Laura you helped make this
book number one among Christmas releases
all weekend so that is awesome fantastic
congrats hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else